today when you're looking at your money
it has to do with your age your risk
tolerance at 64 should not be the risk
tolerance of a 42 year old and shouldn't
be the risk tolerance of a 22 year old
those things vary ages vary the other
part about when it comes down to this is
time Horizon you got short-term midterm
long term what portion of your money do
you need short term if your daughter is
getting married in two years and you
need to be paying for that wedding and
it's going to be a couple hundred
thousand dollars or a hundred thousand
dollars you need to set that money aside
because that time is coming if kids are
about to go to college and they don't
have the GPA to get scholarship you need
that money to be set aside to be paired
that's short term midterm again depends
how old your kids are depends if you're
married depends any of that stuff and
then long term long term